our alice and our peter is it the
crossover of the century
or a glimpse into the dark twisted world
of what fairy tales can actually be
come away reimagines alice in wonderland
and peter pan with the realistic twist
of dark tragedy
in this video we're taking a look at how
these new adventures in wonderland and
neverland bring a whole new message out
of the classic tales and characters we
once thought we knew
i'm afraid i can't explain myself sir
because i'm not myself you know as soon
as the movie opens
we get answers into how exactly they're
going to make this crossover happen
alice and peter are brother and sister
add their older brother david and their
parents jack and rose
and you have the littleton family i need
to mend my white rabbit's waistcoat
but director brenda chatman knew she
didn't want to make this just
another traditional fairy tale story
which isn't surprising
considering she's the one who gave us
the very revolutionary movie
brave yep she's the genius behind merida
and that's the reason why the littletons
are a multi-racial family
because she wasn't afraid to break those
boundaries in fact she didn't even think
twice about casting david oyaloa as jack
instead she realized that her casting
choice actually added a richness to the
story and how people relate to each
other
it turns out in the part of london the
story takes place it was very common to
have interracial couples and she
actually fixed the unrealistic white
centric versions that came before
rose i can explain that's how we get
alice
played by kira chansa who brings to life
a version of her that's arguably way
more interesting than all the others
the creators still stuck very closely to
alice's traditional blue dress and white
apron we even get to see her carry
around a white rabbit for a majority of
the film
but those similarities end at the tea
parties she holds for her stuffed
animals
i'm not a girl i'm a lady she's not like
alice in wonderland
for starters she isn't wealthy although
she does have an aunt who is
and she isn't opposed to growing up as
much as the alice we know
her own father even comments on her
wanting to grow up too fast
if only she knew what becoming an adult
actually meant
am i right she struggles with holding on
to the magic of childhood and
imagination
until the very last moment of the film
we'll touch more on that later when we
discuss just what the message the
creators meant to give their viewers out
of this story
in the meantime let's talk about how
alice contrasts peter perfectly
honest he's all about imagination and
playing and you guessed it
staying young forever the costume
department got both his traditional
green outfit and classic hat perfectly
he runs with the lost boys and dreams
about a life that consists of sword
fights crocodiles and pixie dust
in the end he even ends up leaving his
real life for eternal youth
if come away can be considered a prequel
for anyone it's a prequel for peter
he is probably most like his traditional
version instead of wendy getting whisked
away to neverland
it's peter so what exactly makes his and
alice's lives so tragic
it was a gift from our father their
parents grief
the movie kicks off at the tragic
passing of their older brother david
there aren't exact characters we can
pinpoint that jack and rose played by
angelina jolie herself
are supposed to represent but they could
be in reference to the playing card jack
and the rose garden alice wanders
through in the original versions
jack being a representation of the
playing card makes even more sense when
we learn that he struggles with gambling
while his wife turns to the bottle for
solace
there's also the ironic fact that they
have the same name as titanic's jack and
rose
but is it just a coincidence just like
the 90s romance tale they're both
struggling with class division and
disapproval
stay back stay back
jack and rose represent the realities of
life and bring darkness
into this revamped fairy tale their
characters are the ones who flip the
happy-go-lucky vibes into a
grief-stricken tragedy
in good old childhood fashion alice and
peter used their imaginations to escape
reality instead
but whose coping mechanisms are actually
more dangerous
it's not time to grow up alice their
imaginations lead them to a pawn shop in
the town they live in where they try to
fix their parents money troubles by
pawning a few jewels
and that's where we meet this story's
version of the mad hatter
he's no eccentric johnny depp or a
white-haired old man
he does however wear the classic hat and
has a pretty out of this world wardrobe
but he's
much more intimidating and the kid's
visit with him actually does more harm
than good to their family
your hair wants cutting however
not all the takes on the classic
characters were depressing and tainted
we also get a glimpse of everyone's
favorite fairy tinker bell
well kind of it looks like she's leaving
[Music]
she's not the let's face it the spoiled
fairy we know
instead rose gives her daughter alice a
bell made by a tinker
she tells her the story of how everyone
is born with a fairy just for them and
this bell was hers
when her mother leaves she whispers
we never actually see her come to life
with her classic green dress and
matching adorable slippers
but later on in the film we see the bell
turn to sparkling dust and fly off with
peter as he makes his way to neverland
the queen of hearts there's no dramatic
abnormal looking queen singing off with
your head and come away but the red
queen does make an appearance in alice's
imagination
we even get a reference to her when
alice plays with her playing cards
arguably though the red queen might mean
something a little more to alice
almost like an intrusion of the darkness
that surrounds her everyday life
so if alice and peter see the characters
in their everyday life
what do we see of neverland and
wonderland truth is
not much touch
for neverland we do get to see lost boys
pirate ships crocodiles and sword fights
with captain james hook
but that's almost as far as it goes in
all other terms
neverland and come away has the same
rules as neverland in the regular peter
pan
you never age all fun and no work this
is another place however where the lines
blur between peter and alice in
wonderland
because alice might just be the wendy of
this peter pan story
we see that the movie is actually alice
telling her children the story of her
brother who escaped to neverland
which is extremely similar to the peter
pan sequel where wendy shares her
childhood story
what do you think is alice meant to be
wendy as well but peter
how do we get to neverland fly of course
fly in terms of wonderland there isn't
much to tell
alice still falls down the iconic rabbit
hole but like neverland
wonderland exists in alice's mind
there's even a scene where alice drinks
the bottle labeled drink me
and things around her start to change in
size but in come away the audience
doesn't see it as a magical potion
because we realized the bottle she drank
belonged to her mother
dark we know tastes like
cherry tart so what was the point in
bringing this dark fairy tale mashup to
life
both alice and wonderland and peter pan
are stories about coming of age
learning to let go of your innocence in
the most childlike fashion
imagination but things don't end the
same way and come away
alice may succumb to the trials of
adulthood but peter escapes to a world
of eternal childhood
the similarities in the story could be
the reason why these two specific
stories were used for the movie
to show how different people deal with
grief and the lessons that can be
learned from life's tragedies
i just haven't been myself since just
i just wanted to hold on to him just a
little longer everyone loves a good
fairy tale but for some reason
come away didn't receive the same praise
a movie like frozen or even brave would
have
a lot of viewers felt like the
traditional fairy tales didn't need to
be touched and that mixing them together
didn't leave enough room to explore them
both
if it wasn't obvious the movie wasn't
meant for children
with a lot of the content being pretty
mature instead it takes a look at the
tragedy of life from a child's point of
view
he's going to pay and i know how to
despite the mixed reviews the film has
been getting there's no doubt this
reimagination of peter and alice
completely changed the way we think
about their stories
maybe every fairy tale has the capacity
to teach even grown adults a lesson
about the more tragic parts of life
do you think that come away was meant to
be a prequel to the fairy tales we know
and love
or was it just a twisted take on these
innocent characters
let us know what you think in the
comment section below don't forget to
give come away a thumbs up hit that
subscribe button
and we'll see you in another video
thanks for watching